welcome back to new rock stars it's me
mt and doctor strange and the multiverse
of madness saw doctor strange dreamwalk
into the corpse of his incredibly rude
ponytailed variant to fly to the top of
mount wondergore to fight the mcu's
queen of darkness with his new cloak of
the dead and the damned remember that
darkhold navy has only the finest in
fashion so of course i'm gonna remember
that but yeah um what even happened to
corpster strange anyway because i don't
know about you but the only dark souls
that should be giving you misery in your
life should be inside your playstation 4
and not your neighboring stevens corpse
so our new source of supreme wong might
probably want to check up on that
because a couple of things can go wrong
here i don't even want to know but first
do not forget to pick up our latest
obsession shirt inspired by doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness it
is so nice it's not gonna last forever
so hit up newrockstarsmerch.com to pick
it up today all right so to recap
multiverse of madness ended with a
remorseful wando maximoff deciding to
destroy the dark cold castle around
herself so that nobody on the planet
would ever be tempted by those dark ass
spells again seemingly choosing to
sacrifice herself in the process as she
herself probably figured that she was
too far gone for any type of redemption
especially after her own horrific
experience with one darkhold corrupted
agatha harkness in the town of west view
new jersey that got her hooked on
kathann's magic cuckoo juice in the
first place where wanda of course would
learn that agatha harkness's own mother
tried to kill her daughter for staying
up past her bedtime reading the devil's
fanfiction called the darkhold because
agatha all along was dark magicka too
far gone by the darkholds hold and so
like mama harkness in 1693 and the 838
pizza papa illuminati wanna knew what
had to be done though let's be real here
juana maximoff is very likely not dead
by the end of this movie because the one
big rule the mcu is if you don't see a
body then the death didn't officially
happen and this much is of course also
true with this damn soul-infused corpse
of a ponytail doctor strange a body that
most people assumed to be dead and
buried in the rubble with all that wanda
wreckage however what do they say about
assuming things y'all it makes an ass
out of you and me and me and a potential
big problem for doctor strange three why
well the good doctor didn't necessarily
leave his scare bnb corpse the way he
found it because uh not everybody
checked out because that body still got
all those spirits of the damned inside
of it spirits that were originally
trapped within the confines of the dark
hole itself seemingly manifesting only
when a magic user breaks the natural law
and does something crazy with a new
style of magic that we've yet seen in
the mcu necromancy the reanimation of
the dead something that the multiverse
of madness prequel wanda vision teases
when agatha talks to wanda about her
darkhold inspired pietro plans a
christolo possession necromancy was a
non-starter since your real brother's
body is on another continent
not to mention full of holes using the
dark chaos magic within the dark hole to
hijack the brain of a dead body and then
force that dead body to move around
seems to be what necromancy in the
marvel cinematic universe is almost like
a sort of encephalopathy which is just a
fancy word for a disease or a catalyst
that affects the way the human brain
functions in a word a lot of people like
me heard for the first time in that what
if zombies episode when spider-man and
the rest of the cast of the walking dead
chat with the ultimate symptoid
about the exact cause for the zombie
outbreak could that mean the infection
is some kind of encephalopathy brain
stuff precisely the virus overloads the
brain's limbic system this sort of
implies to me that whether it's a dark
viral entity from the quantum realm or a
dark chaotic magic infused demon
security from the darkhold as long as
there is a type of dark evil energy
within a dead person's brain that brain
can be hijacked and rebooted like a
microchip to allow the limbs to move in
the body to walk talk and help wang off
the evil rock and if these dark spirits
are still in possession of the body of
ponytail strange this says to me that
these demons of the darkhold are damned
no more and have found a new home to be
miserable together in inside of their
new human host that will in my opinion
very likely be the mcu's version of mr
misery one of doctor strange's craziest
and most you know scariest foes ever
who's essentially the sentient
representation of all the darkness and
pain comic book doctor strange picked up
from doing all that magic and he
basically just shoved all of that misery
into the undercroft or basement of the
sanctum sanctorum and called it the
thing in the cellar and that thing would
later come back to bite its father in
the ass by trying to kill him and feed
off the fear and misery of everyone in
the neighborhood like these are the
eternal consequences the darkhold damned
warns range that he would incur if he
did not seize his dreamwalk and if
there's anything doctor strange doesn't
like to do it's you know paying the bill
when it comes due just like his buddy
mordo chastise him about before he
dedicated his life to murdering this
magic rule breaker of a man before he
plays around with dark and magical
elements that he doesn't understand you
still think there will be no
consequences strange
no price to pay
we broke our rules just like her
the bill
comes
due
always but of course doctor strange
would ignore these damned creatures and
infuse himself with the spirit power of
these demons to fight the scarlet witch
which is something that comic book
strange does with mr misery in the
comics when he's forced to fuse with mr
misery to fight off one of my personal
favorite doctor strange villains of all
time the imperator a dude from another
dimension who wants to kill all magic
users of the multiverse well you know
that other dimension is also uh the
schuma gore have to mention so i don't
necessarily blame that man and someone i
hope to god is coming to the mcu to team
up with mordo because he straight up
just gore the god butcher for magic
people and you know
now that frog man is in the mcu
wong's got some backup in case that ever
happens
i'm so excited i'm so happy and i very
much believe that director sam raimi
took inspiration from the very pages of
2015's doctor strange number 10 to make
this final fight between strange and
wanda and much like that battle ended in
the comics it seems like strange has
left this new miserable and unkillable
zombie-like being of his creation
unattended within the rubble of
wondergore left to roam the world and
feed off the misery of others as mr
misery however speaking of zombies much
like i hinted at earlier with that
what-if callback we could also be
looking at a scenario where this corpse
doctor strange is the first step to
marvel zombies in the live action 616
universe because these damned beings
that used to be within the darkhold are
technically a form of virus infecting
doctor strange through the darkhold
which could mean that this mr misery
could be the catalyst for and the leader
of a potential live-action marvel
zombies in doctor strange 3 and beyond
but let's talk about something that
happens right before doctor strange
starts wielding these dark souls like
the anti-wanda weapon that they were
because right as doctor strange gains
the confidence to wield his new dark
power one of those demons of the damned
that didn't jump out of his eyeball to
fight christine retreated back into the
brain of dr strange likely being the
very dark element that remained behind
to become the headache-inducing third
eye at the end of the film because the
mr misery entity from the comics is not
one lacking in the random eyeballs
coming out of nowhere department which
could make this mr misery third eye on
616 doctor strange his eternal
consequence to bear with mr sinister
potentially always having a link to his
creator doctor strange due to one of
their own being stuck in his mind and on
his forehead but that is what i believe
happened to the corpse of doctor strange
in multiverse of madness what do you
guys think do you guys think that the
corpse is like fully dead do you guys
think that the corpse could have
reanimated wanda because you know wanda
is definitely not dead so like maybe
that could be the reason why she
survived speculate in the comment
section below my speculation nation nerd
babies but anyways thank you guys so
much for watching this video you can
follow me at message aiming on twitter
to see me tweet some weird [ __ ] but more
importantly you can follow new rockstars
make sure to hit that notification but
you get notifications every time we
upload a video and of course please hit
up new rockstarsmerch.com so you can get
our latest obsession shirt inspired by
dr strange in the multiverse of madness
the design is really cool but it's not
gonna last forever but anyways thank you
guys so much for watching i love you
guys so much and i'll see you guys later
goodbye
[Music]
you